pour le match prochain match contre les
ivoiriens on est obligé de gagner obligé
de gagner pour se qualifier il faudra
sortir un gros match contre un grand
pays africain est dos au mur l'algérie
est un pays qui bâtit qui donne tout et
qui qui est présent dans c dans ces
grands rendez vous on va gagner ce match
pour le faire
ma joie en algérie parce qu'on est mise
algérien le football ça coule de
l'encens
le match contre l'algérie
pour nous voir number one chicago
qualification au prochain tour ce que
nous étions se trouve ça va pas
travailler
dans ces qualifiés au revoir
isync 10 parts of the pitch in the
disaster everybody knows
sow voit l'asn before de pitch in this
correct heidi dans cette fantastique is
correct le derf des games after game of
course when you use de pitch squid
difficult to maintain et une bonne
condition elle n'est pas dans les pas de
niveau
qui permet une fluidité totale et ce
qu'on espère des grands tournois comme
une coupe d'afrique